he's an environmentalist and former
executive director of Friends of the
Earth he's the author of what has nature
ever done for us how money really does
grow on trees what nature does for
Britain and rainforests dispatches from
Earth's most vital frontlines he's also
the co-author with the Prince of Wales
of Harmony a new way of looking at our
world thank you thank you Richard good
evening ladies and gentlemen I have to
say that in my long career as an
environmentalist I've reached the
conclusion that the question we're
debating this evening is the most
important of all namely what kind of
economic system is going to enable us to
navigate the climate change and nature
emergency and while many people talk
about population growth and the fact
that our numbers have tripled since 1950
bear in mind that the size of the global
economy has increased tenfold and the
consequences of that we can see in
elevated greenhouse gas emissions the
mass extinction of animals and plants
and ecological degradation on a global
scale if you look at the way different
economies have greeted these trends over
the decades it's largely been seen as
the price of progress with both
socialist and capitalist systems both
seeking to expand output as the means of
achieving human wellbeing both systems
capitalist and socialist saw growth as
their most vital and essential objective
one promoted the process via markets
private property and corporations the
other via central planning state
ownership of Industry and workers
managing the organizations that employed
them both saw the rapid exploitation of
natural resources as central to their
plans to expand GDP they both wanted to
expand the size of the pie with
capitalists expecting the wealth to
trickle down through society and
socialists engaging in more or less
active redistribution
looking at the last hundred years of
economic experiments conducted under
those two banners it's fair to say that
we have not yet invented a large-scale
economic system that can be regarded as
ecologically sustainable and as previous
speakers have pointed out this evening
this is now a matter of grave urgency we
have to shift from where we are to a
sustainable economy in a matter of years
and as we consider the importance of
urgency just bear in mind that pretty
much all democracies across the world
vote for some kind of capitalist system
whether it's the socially progressive
form that you see in some of the
Scandinavian countries or the neoliberal
excesses of the United States broadly
speaking that is what citizens back if
we are going to make this shift in time
then we're going to need to find ways of
getting citizens to back that economic
transformation in ways that they would
like and looking at the world from where
I see it at the moment is going to be
most likely to do that through some form
of capitalist transformation changing
the system that we have rather than
pushing it off a cliff and if we are to
succeed then we need to harness the
dynamic innovation of markets of
competition and the inventiveness that
comes with the profit motive if we're
going to do that what kind of system
might we envisage so unlike the other
side this evening ladies and gentle but
I'm going to give you some solutions
rather than simply a diagnosis of the
problem and it's not going to be a
five-year Soviet plan it's going to be a
five-point capitalist transformation
program point one in this transformation
program is to adopt legal frameworks
adopted by governments to embed hard
caps to reflect the need to reduce to
zero greenhouse gas emissions and to
restore the natural environment that
needs to be done globally through the
Convention on biodiversity and the
convention on climate change and
domestically through things like the
climate change act and the environment
acts that was introduced into Parliament
today we need targets set out in law
that reflect the scale of the ecological
emergency once we've established the
caps we need to put in place the
tools and the policies to meet those new
goals we can do this through the
regulation on emission standards through
the regulation of the financial markets
supportive trade policy and of course in
relation to climate change a price on
carbon imagine what would happen if over
the next ten years we introduced a 100
pounds carbon tax per Tung ten pounds a
year rising between 2020 and 2030 that
would send a very clear signal that it's
time to get out of fossil fuels it would
be transformative and it could be part
of a wider ecological tax reform program
whereby people on lower incomes have
their income tax reduced and instead we
levy taxation on pollution and waste 3
in this plan would be a shift of the
subsidies regime been pointed out
already quite rightly that hundreds of
billions of pounds are awarded to fossil
fuel corporations and industrial
agriculture across the globe every year
we need to switch those subsidies into
the cleaner and greener alternatives
sustainable regenerative agriculture
renewable energy amongst them these
three steps hard limits new regulatory
tools and reoriented subsidies would
ensure that the ultimate means of
economic activity namely a healthy
biosphere would be better protected on
top of this however it would also be
necessary to correct the rather
fundamental fact that near neoliberal
capitalism has lost sight of why it
exists in the first place this is why
parts four and five of the
transformation plan are about ensuring
that capitalism delivers long-term
wellbeing for all rather than hoping
that self-interested buyers and sellers
will deliver that automatically we know
that they won't do so part four would be
the adoption of new measures to judge
economic success embracing human
wellbeing an ecological sustainability
as central measures of performance of
the economy not simple crude GDP that
would be put into the dustbin of history
where it belongs instead of measuring
and celebrating increased consumption
and waste which is basically what GDP
growth does we would have economic
measure
- instead celebrate long happy and
sustainable lives for everybody part
five would focus on the private sector
companies there at the very being heart
of the capitalist system they would be
subject to new laws requiring that they
be driven by a purpose to promote the
well-being of people and society not
simply the interests of shareholders
companies would still harness markets
profits and innovation but they would do
it against a new set of goals that were
set out in new company laws they would
still seek profit but not does not
necessarily profit maximization nor
profit via any legal route their purpose
would be sustainable development
governments can legislate for all of
these things and in different parts of
the world in different ways they're
beginning to do it we need to put super
charges on that agenda however my
argument is evening is not predicated on
the view that it's capitalism per se
does cause the mess we are in but rather
the economic system more broadly whether
it be capitalist socialist or anything
else that we've invented we are very
very short of time people want positive
alternatives that they can vote for
looking around the world where people
presently past cast their votes I would
say the best chance we've got is to
change capitalism to invest in its
transformation not to push it off a
cliff because that will end in even more
certain disaster thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you very much